>> Bret: MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
AT CNN ARE HOPING THIS NEW WEEK
PLAYS OUT MUCH BETTER THAN THE
LAST.
THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR THE NETWORK.
FOX NEWS MEDIA NETWORK AND HOST
OF MEDIA BUZZ HOWARD KURTZ SHOWS
US TONIGHT.
>> IT'S BEEN A WEEK OF SETBACKS
FOR CNN.
THE NETWORK LONG TIME
CONTRIBUTOR RICK SANTORUM ONE OF
ITS CONSERVATIVE VOICES OVER THE
WEEKEND AFTER THE FORMER SENATOR
INSULTED AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
>> THERE IS NOTHING HERE, YES,
WE HAVE NATIVE AMERICANS BUT
CANDIDLY THERE ISN'T MUCH NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURE IN AMERICAN
CULTURE.
>> AFTER AN OUTCRY SANTORUM
TRIED TO DO DAMAGE CONTROL ON
CHRIS CUOMO'S SHOW BUT REFUSED
TO APOLOGIZE.
>> I MISSPOKE IN THIS RESPECT.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE FOUNDING
AND PRINCIPLES EMBODIED IN THE
FOUNDING.
>> SANTORUM SAYS HE KNEW HE
WOULD BE PROVIDING COMMENTARY
THAT IS NOT REGULARLY HEARD BY
THE TYPICAL CNN VIEWER.
CUOMO FOR HIS PART IS STILL
DEALING FROM THE FALLOUT FOR
PRIVATELY ADVISING HIS BROTHER
ANDREW CUOMO ON DEALING WITH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS BY
JOINING CONFERENCE CALLS THAT
INCLUDED THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR'S
TOP AIDES AND ADVISERS THAT LED
TO A PRIME TIME APOLOGY.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHY THAT WAS A
PROBLEM FOR CNN IT WILL NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT WAS A MISTAKE.
>> I THINK HE MADE A HUGE
MISTAKE BY BEING ON THAT CALL.
I MEAN, YOU JUST DON'T WANT TO
BE PART OF THE OFFICIAL
APPARATUS OF THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK'S OFFICE.
>> CNN CALLED CUOMO'S ACTIONS
INAPPROPRIATE BUT HAS RESISTED
CALLS TO PUNISH HIM THE NETWORK
ALSO CUT TIES WITH MIDDLE EAST
FREELANCER RAAJA FOR TWEETING TO
80,000 FOLLOWERS THAT THE WORLD
NEEDS ANOTHER HITLER AND CALLING
THE ISRAELIS TERRORISTS SEVEN
YEARS AFTER MAKING SIMILAR
PRO-HITLER COMMENTS.
CNN CALLED THOSE STATEMENTS
ABHORRENT.
ALL THIS TAKING PLACE AS CNN IS
GETTING YET ANOTHER CORPORATE
OWNER.
THREE YEARS AFTER BEING BOUGHT
BY AT&T, THE NETWORK WILL JOIN A
UNIT NEWLY MERGED WITH
DISCOVERY.
CHRIS CUOMO APOLOGY ENABLES HIM
AND HIS BOSSES TO MODIFY ON.
SANTORUM'S REFUSAL AND HIS FOUR
YEAR RUN AT THE NETWORK.
THIS MEANS CNN WHICH HAS LOST
OTHER CONSERVATIVE CONTRIBUTORS
TO VARIOUS CONTROVERSY NOW HAS
ONE LESS PROMINENT REPUBLICAN
VOICE.
BRET?
>> Bret: HOWIE, GOVERNOR CUOMO
WAS ASKED ABOUT HIS BROTHER
TODAY.
WHAT DID HE TELL REPORTERS?
>> BRET, GOVERNOR CUOMO SAID
CHRIS IS MY BEST FRIEND.
I DON'T ALWAYS FOLLOW HIS ADVICE
AND THEN HE SAID THIS I TALK TO
JOURNALISTS ABOUT SITUATIONS ALL
THE TIME AND THEY TELL ME THEIR
THOUGHTS AND OFFER THEIR ADVICE.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER
UNNAMED JOURNALISTS SAY IN
SCHMOOZING CUOMO, BUT THEY ARE
NOT RELATED TO HIM AND SECONDLY,
THEY ARE NOT PARTICIPATING IN
DAMAGE CONTROL STRATEGY SESSIONS
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR AND
HIS TOP STAFF.
THAT SEEMED LIKE A PRETTY
OBVIOUS DEFLECTION BROTHER